there's been some incredibly exciting
news in the last 24 hours
and one of my favorite sci-fi shows of
all time
is coming back and it's official this is
psytrek
so i've always been a trekkie i love
star trek i
love everything about star trek even
star trek i don't like
it's been a long road
to here but there is another tv show
that's got
a very special place for my heart
stargate
and it's official it's coming back
they didn't go for it they didn't
approve the mission
oh no they did that once they knew the
stakes and the whole
fate of the universe stuff both
president hammond realized we had no
choice
he sends good luck godspeed and all
those things he says when he thinks
we're gonna die
so what didn't they go for the name i
suggested for the ship
yeah yeah sir we can't call it the
enterprise why not
so even though this has been teased for
quite a few years now even
you know the last two years brad wright
has been talking about this
and it has been made official mgm
are going to produce an animated series
an animated series of four adults
i'm hoping something along the lines of
lower decks or something like that
that'd be really cool this station is
amazing and they have romulan whiskey
and i bet you thought it was gonna be
green but it's actually blue it's this
very beautiful color romulan whiskey is
against regulation yeah cause it's
awesome oh man they got all sorts of
great stuff
oh come on check this out be careful
with that pretty sweet red
yeah it's a klingon bat um bat uh bat i
don't know i'm not a scientist it
doesn't matter shut up i got it from an
old guy with an ipad
and a proper tv series um
this is incredibly exciting for me um
both of these tv series will
be shown on amazon prime so where has
this come about how has this happened
well like i say brad wright the producer
of sg1 atlantis and
sgu hgu i hate that show talk about that
a bit more in a second
um has been talking about this the last
two years and he's been saying how about
he's been desperately trying to develop
this series for quite a long time now
but it's finally been green lighted so
why is it being relighted now well
an sg-1 or sg series like this is quite
expensive
the problem is mgm is actually 2.4
billion dollars in debt at the moment
and obviously they've covered over the
last 18 months has not helped that
situation any
um delays to their biggest franchise the
james bond series
has not helped that situation any so
they
about two years ago they did actually
put themselves up for sale now
even though the sale isn't actually
finalized yet
amazon are already starting to create
partnership deals
with mgm this is the first probably big
project
partnered with amazon that's been
announced so what can we expect from the
new series
well brad wright has been talking in
interviews and he was talking about
wanting to have a younger more exciting
cast and something that was more
relevant to younger people today
he was asked in the interview do you
mean stargate academy
and he sort of went oh no i don't want
to say much more because that's getting
a bit close to the truth
um i'm really hoping that brad wright
isn't going to actually shoot himself in
the foot with his tv series before we
even get started
along the lines that they did with sgu
i don't understand why science fiction
tv series have to over complicate things
all the time
why can't you just keep something simple
along the lines of star trek star trek
the next generation you have a ship
you have a crew they go and explore
there is a million different
opportunities and possibilities where
the tv show can go
but then you do star trek enterprise a
brilliant
simple premise how do we see the
federation begin
and they shoot themselves in the foot
immediately by over complicating it
with a bunch of time wars and
sula barn and all this sort of thing
that just ruined the tv show from the
beginning
and limited the possibilities of where
they could go with it that is basically
what they did with sg universe
they tried in my opinion to copy the
style of battlestar galactica they
wanted to do something that was a bit
more
artistic and they limited themselves
with the storyline immediately by
putting themselves on the ship in the
middle of
nowhere literally between two universes
literally the middle of nowhere
um they limited what they could do with
the series they wanted to make it maybe
more
character-based but what they did was
they made it boring
now i'm really hoping they don't do that
with this new series
and i'm really hoping they do something
that gives them a million opportunities
like sg-1 and they don't shoot
themselves in the foot
immediately so there's any chance of the
any of the original cast returning for
this new series
well michael shanks was doing an
interview with his wife
um lexa doi now alexa we know from the
later series of um
stargate where she was the doctor but
also we know from the brilliant and
underrated andromeda series
so michael was talking about stargate
and his loves and
his regrets from the series but then he
did speak
about the possibility of returning to a
new series
he spoke about how brad right approached
him about a new series
and his interest in developing something
michael was really interested in this
and actually seems to want to get
involved in
in the creation side of it and more
directing and things which he has done
in the past
but also could we see potentially
a stargate academy or some sort of new
stargate sg-1 team
led or maybe taught
by the daniel jackson character maybe he
will be a mentor
or something along those lines i don't
think he'd be the new general but
maybe sg-1 command is not going to be
military anymore maybe it's going to be
civilian
and dan jackson is actually in command
it's one possibility
so what am i hoping for from this series
like i said i'm really hoping for
something
simple and we're hoping for a simple
premise that they can then really
explore and go anywhere with i'm hoping
for
new bad guys i want to see what the goal
will do to are they alright going to
make a return
but mainly we want to see a new bad guy
the goal will
obviously slip from power who is
replacing that power there's whenever
there's a power vacuum
somebody always steps up who is it this
time i also want to see
where the human species has got because
we have all the technology from
the asgard we have the technology from
the battle with the ori where are we now
with that
is it open to the public do the public
know about this
greater universe that we've stepped into
during the s21 series
or is it still secret there is a million
possibilities where sg
series could go and i can't wait to see
what they do
okay so thank you if you are new to the
channel but you are because
it's a new channel please like and
subscribe hit that bell notification so
you get all our news videos
we're going to be doing watch longs
debates
um i'll be putting adverts for new
videos as they come out
um we'll be seeing new trailers for
films everything and everything that
really excites me in the tv and movie
world
was going to be on this channel but also
it's a fan channel so i want you guys to
get involved too
so please drop a comment what do you
think
about the new sg series and what do you
think
and where do you think they should take
it thanks very much and uh
see you next time dial it up walter
yes sir
chevron one encoded
that is how we're supposed to travel
light years across the galaxy to other
planets
you know i like to think that i handled
myself well but
i imagine i went a bit crazy cooped up
on that [ __ ] for so long
chevron3 encoded you know tilt did tell
me some things i learned from the asgard
knowledge base
he did like what
oh boy were they chevron
beggars can't be choosers better late
than never
look before you leap the best things in
life are free
let me guess beauty is only skin deep
silence is golden number five encoded
jack of all trades master of none
nothing ventured
nothing gained life is too short
chevron's six encoded
good things come to those who wait you
know
as hard as it is for us not knowing
it must be torture for you not to tell
us
indeed
chevron 7 is locked
[Music]
good luck just another everyday mission
to save the galaxy sir
indeed
[Music]
godspeed
[Music]
[Music]
you